[Music]
hi my name is marcin farmer technologist
I was born in Poland now in the US I
started group called open source ecology
we've identified the 50 most important
machines that we think takes for modern
life to exist things from tractors bread
ovens circuit makers then we set out to
create an open-source DIY do-it-yourself
version that anyone can build and
maintain at a fraction of the cost we
call this the global village
Construction Set so let me tell you a
story so I finished my twenties with a
PhD in fusion energy and I discovered I
was useless
I had no practical skills I mean the
world presented me with options and I
took them I guess you can call it the
consumer lifestyle so I started a farm
in Missouri and learned about the
economics of farming
I bought a tractor then it broke I paid
to get it repaired then it broke again
and pretty soon I was broke too I
realized that the truly appropriate
low-cost tools that I needed to start a
sustainable farm and settlement just
didn't exist yet I needed tools that
were robust modular highly efficient and
optimized low cost made from local and
recycled materials that would last a
lifetime not designed for obsolescence I
found that I would have to build them
myself so I did just that and I tested
them and I found that industrial
productivity can be achieved on a small
scale so then I published the 3d designs
schematics instructional videos and
budgets on a wiki then contributors from
all over the world began showing up
prototyping new machines during
dedicated project visits so far we have
prototype 8 of the 50 machines and now
the project is beginning to grow on its
own
we know that open-source has succeeded
with tools for managing knowledge and
creativity and the same is starting to
happen with hardware - we're focusing on
hardware because it is hardware that can
change people's lives in such tangible
material ways if we can lower the
barriers to farming building
manufacturing that we can unleash just
massive amounts of human potential
that's not only in the developing world
our tools are being made for the
American farmer Builder entrepreneur
maker we've seen lots of excitement from
these people who can now start a
construction business parts
manufacturing organic CSA or just
selling power back to the grid our goal
is a repository of published design so
clear so complete that a single burned
DVD is effectively a civilization
starter kit I've planted a hundred trees
in a day I've pressed five thousand
bricks in one day from the dirt beneath
my feet and built a tractor in six days
from what I've seen this is only the
beginning if this idea is truly sound
then the implications are significant a
greater distribution of the means of
production environmentally sound supply
chains and the newly relevant DIY maker
culture can hope to transcend artificial
scarcity we're exploring the limits of
what we all can do to make a better
world with open hardware technology
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]